and it was regularly seeing the family
or propels you are there any assisted in
your past truly where you couldn't get
over it and why I mean but by the way by
the way that's the same answer for
everybody in this room that's what
humans are good at we all fail we've all
failed like therapy I I my parents
haven't been killed my child
I mean there's people that have their
children die like could you imagine like
the [ __ ] I deal like I'm like listen
unfortunately or fortunately depends on
how one wants to look at it I'm a pretty
optimistic guy I lost three of my four
grandparents before I was really before
I knew them two before I was born in one
very early on like so you know it's easy
for me to be happy I have my [ __ ] in the
right order the health and well-being of
my family and there's nothing even
remotely close to that not even not even
remotely people have gotten through much
worse this is why I'm trying to recall
our grandparents and our
great-grandparents people were
persecuted and killed like I just we do
not have real headaches you know I don't
know why I have this highly emotional
and then completely unemotional part of
me but I mix them together to create the
balance and that's what works for me so
of course there's nothing that I
couldn't get upfront like every other
human ever besides somebody who now
lives in some weird cave that we don't
know about you know what I mean we are
strong as [ __ ] we're really [ __ ]
strong we're just being sold that we're
not because there's a lot of money a lot
of money and telling us that we're not
pretty enough thin enough smart enough
good enough [ __ ] that I want to tell you
you're the [ __ ] best go do [ __ ]
don't hire nothing about that it was
actually do [ __ ]